You can see them everywhere in Lagos: people
relieving themselves outdoors, in the open.
One of every four Nigerians has no access
to a proper toilet.
It has been so difficult for us.
What we do is, we come to this river here
to excrete ourselves.”
+++
The way they relieve themselves is disturbing
to those of us living here.
Because out in the open, everyone can see
them.
The government should at least build a cover
so we can’t see them.
It is very difficult for us.
We have to go to the river to poo.
Some women poo inside a bucket, and then dump
it into the river.
It is not good.”+++
20 million people live in this overcrowded
megacity.
Bad hygiene and a lack of sufficient toilets
are endangering people's health in the poorer
districts.
Ironically, it's easier to find a mobile phone
than a toilet.
You find warnings like this everywhere in
Lagos.
And yet they are always ignored.
Because there are simply no alternatives.
The lack of toilets is turning into a big
business for some people.
Jeremiah Jere installed some "porta potties"
near a bus station.
Now he makes about 30 Euros a day.
Number one costs 10 cents, number two will
cost
you 25 cents.
It's a good business!
When you come here to relieve yourself, it
will save you from disgrace.
You know, urinating is an emergency sometimes.
Most of the time, people in an area like this
relieve themselves anywhere, when it is urgent.
But if they begin to feel it gradually, they
can come to this place.
This is where Jere's toilets are produced.
Lanre Akinwale's company is the only one in
Nigeria that builds mobile toilets.
It employs thirty-one people, and business
is booming.
With a population of almost 200 million, Nigeria
provides a huge market for his product.
Still, Akinwale is troubled by the current
situation, and says the government alone,
is not to blame.
We need to begin to change the mentality of
the people.
Even if you tell some people go and use the
toilet, they will tell you that they prefer
to go into the bush.
They prefer it, because the breeze is blowing
there.
That’s the mentality.
But it is not good for us.
So at it is now, we need to put on some strict
measures to stop this open defecation.
The government did create an emergency plan.
But up until now, almost nothing has changed.
The toilet crisis in Lagos clearly remains
a problem that needs an urgent solution.